Incredible
the last day
have put America in such jeopardy in so
many ways.
I mean the fact of these trillions of
dollars of debt we have now,
that's going to be a huge burden to
arrive with the fact that global
warming,
as nothing has been done about it.
Even Mccain now says he's,
you think something has to be done about
it.
Lord knows he changes his mind so often.
We don't know how long that will stay,
but I'm,
I'm the Iraq war of course is a huge
issue.
And the economy,
unemployment,
immigration,
I mean the person who's job one should
really want,
um,
these are,
these are really incredible issues.
I think from what I've seen of him,
um,
his basic intelligence will allow him to
assemble a team.
I mean,
basically a president is a team.
It's hardly a single person will allow
him to assemble people to help begin
those problems.
And the fact that he's such an inspired
arbiter or some people almost hold
against him,
I think is very,
very crucial.
Very crucial at this time that someone
will be able to speak and convince
people what they have to do,
convince the country,
convince them that there's hope.
First of all.
I mean,
America has never apparently in all the
polls express so much of a lack of hope
in anything.
And I think the fact that he is that
inspiring could be very,
very important.
Will be very assuming you went to
bruce.
I mean,
that's where Kennedy is remembered for
Kennedy made a lot of terrible mistakes.
But what he's remembered for is that,
that there was a moment when people felt
as though there were light.
I think that's partly,
that's a good part of what a leader
does.
A leader finds the positive things,
finds what we can do.
Um,
the reason Bush's administration was so
despairing to so many of us was that it
was based in fear.
It was a constant repetition of fear.
We have to be afraid of this.
So we have to do that.
We have to be afraid of that.
So we can do this.
And um,
and this is what's happened is that
people now are really in a state of
anguish,
didn't have to be that way.